Mark can you ask me some things about  soccer that you're curious about yeah I  am what happened to his knee there he  was called a herniated disc in his  labrum okay ask me other questions all  right what formation should they get  into you think I mean V that's what most  people would say Flying V I don't think  that they should do flying B I think  they should do probably shotgun and uh  if that doesn't work then I would go  into like yeah well you can say it and  then and then yeah so I would sorry  either shotgun or am back yeah what  is shotgun um what is shotgun yeah which  formation is it yeah I've never heard of  that in soccer man I got a joke I can't  stay man sure do I have a joke I'd like  to say but I can't did you play AYSO  growing up what does that mean soccer  league soccer I didn't play soccer my  parents were heterosexual yeah I know so  they did not allow us to do that